[Music]
is very to think filmmakers are
literally trying to put us with a length
of these logos at this point it's almost
as if wait was that noise born with
extraordinary abilities narration and
like most x-men movies this narration is
rehashed overly pompous poetic
meandering about genetic mutation give
someone wings and they may fly too close
to the Sun give a movie narration and
may prematurely expose it all over
itself also they twist cliche blue in
the x-men story while someone might get
wings they still have to obey the laws
of physics and are unable to fly too
close to the Sun like Icarus did
allegory be damned these mutants also
had the ability to rewrite history since
the Egyptian pyramids weren't even
started until a thousand years after
this hey even though this is a secret
ceremony and you don't need to
intimidate anyone be sure to snarl so we
can see how much of an evil bastard you
are don't worry it's a digital surgery
scar those heal up in 2.8 gigahertz Mali
watch the power of the Sun infused this
pyramid with solar power through
something that looks like an ancient
oversized microchip that melts gold and
races the platforms I realize it's
probably best that I not try and figure
out how this whole process is bull this
block takes out many other support beams
that are roughly the same size and not
only never slows down but actually
gained speed
oh hi Oscar Isaac guess this is the last
time we'll be seeing you at least your
real face and voice and non-verbally
Modi luckily for apocalypse and this
movie they dug the sub-basement of this
pyramid all the way to hell this icy
miss is so effective at blocking heavy
rocks it actually makes me wonder why
this wasn't done more often when they
were above ground getting hit by heavy
rocks here's the animated title sequence
and oh look Monalisa huh also we
interrupt this awkward segue from
ancient Egypt to the 1980s to show you a
sculpture of Jesus carrying a cross
through a tunnel by candlelight this is
just some place in Ohio no need for
specifics just no high ohing it up in
here are you kidding here this high
school kid is going through mutant
adolescents during a lecture on mutants
do I have that right you fuckin clowns
why don't you stop by the principal's
office and explain to him that you're
disrupting class again Jesus lady
he just politely asked to go to the
bathroom it's not like it was smoking
PCP during your bull mutant presentation
Scots powerful laser eyes are no match
for the integrity of a bathroom stall
which protects the bully somehow but
destroy everything else so that Scott
can remain guiltless well at least they
aren't sexualizing mystique in this
movie also this is ten years later right
shouldn't she be close to turning into
Rebecca remain by now it is my belief
that roughly 45% of the Marvel Universe
have their origin stories rooted in
fighting people in cage match
and someone tell me how Nightcrawler a
got captured and be stayed captured also
wait you're matching it teleporter up
against a guy with wings I know this is
underground fighting and rules are not a
concern this fight is the very
definition of unfair and anyone who
blindly bet on angels should be storming
the betting windows after Nightcrawler
wins easily also I can see this as a
cage with electric current running
through it but how was net Karl are not
able to transport through it anyway he
can't just transport outside
hey I'm mystique can impersonate anyone
but she uses her power to change clothes
mid scene in case you confused it for
Bruce Kyle Kentucky there was no fucking
way Eric's been hiding out anywhere
after the attack on Washington that no
one can recognize him as Ludacris to
Superman Clark Kent levels I mean they
teach about him in Ohio schools no one
will be seated during the magneto has a
happy marriage and a child who has
befriended a fucking deer and they all
visit the well see where did you learn
that song papa I learned it from my
parents and they learned it from their
parents and then from there ladies and
gentlemen the x-men and one day you know
sang it 210
provided you don't get killed in a freak
arrow accident what's happened to them
Thanks oh they were horribly murdered in
a concentration camp while I was
tortured by Kevin Bacon but that's a
story for another night darling now get
some sleep
I've had just about enough of these
glamour shots of this sign thank you
very much that has now stop fresh
without remembrance ah th white yet
again Professor X is caught quoting
classic literature instead of teaching
these kids about how to fight evil
whatever
I guess poetry matters and somehow I
mean that is what the characters are
gonna think at the end of this movie
after a global war with apocalypse know
what good is a school for mutants that
just teaches the regular ap creative
writing really movie you list Ohio in
one location East Berlin in another but
now it's the full Cairo Egypt pick a
goddamn format already Jesus we first
saw Moya in x-men first class which was
set in 1962 she has no powers but in
1983 she still looks the same as she did
then even though this hole is partially
blocked by carpets and an unconscious
dude The Sun will still shine enough to
make this pyramid thing he do its thing
now conveniently coincidental that
you're here right now thousands of years
after this asshole was entombed
right as he's being resurrected and you
have x-men ties this is a whole bunch of
discount Inner Earth Tron graphics that
does not bring us any closer to
understanding the bull contraption and
just before this fucker awakens I'd like
to remind the viewing audience that the
superhero movie is entirely predicated
on the idea of an ancient all-powerful
God going to sleep long ago and then
waking up just as the producers of Days
of Future past we're looking for sequel
ideas Rose Byrne
is laura croft ex person because someone
decided to wake up apocalypse right now
an earthquake in egypt was felt all the
way to Germany and causes Eric to use
his powers to save someone adding him as
a mutant okay if it was that damn
powerful Egypt should be in ruins
also I'm no seismologist but an
earthquake felt all over the world would
probably be kind of devastating to the
entire world right how does a quake in
Egypt register all over the world
without kind of fucking up the Earth's
tectonic makeup and I'm much more
permanent and we're all gonna die
fashion no you don't know what it's like
to be afraid to shut your eyes to be
trapped inside your own head gene says
this too literally the only person in
the world who does know exactly what
this is like
Charles locates his ex-girlfriend
halfway around the world but somehow
misses the most powerful mutant the
world has ever known that has literally
steps away from her she looks amazing
she's barely aged today I know right
that should raise some red flags of some
kind I told you who my boss the first
night I met you I trusted you then I
need you to trust me now Jesus Eric told
his girl he was one of the world's most
dangerous fugitives on the first date
and she stuck with him I guess the
future mrs. Lynde sure had already seen
shame haha we've somehow surreptitiously
kidnapped your daughter and took her to
this random place in the woods that we
knew you'd find eventually premature
relation also could this accidental
arrowing actually happen
possibly does it feel manufactured to
make Eric angry at humans again I think
that's the sin here also this arrow
Pierce is both Nina and Magda partly
because life hates Eric more than any
other person who ever lived but also
because either one of them continuing to
live in this world means no Magneto so
these deaths are for your entertainment
assholes recently awoke an all-powerful
God wastes his first few hours wandering
through an Egyptian farmers market
because he's so shocked at the
advancement of society in his absence
he's unable to even remember this world
domination plan I guess luckily Yong
storm just happens to be here to get
caught shoplifting by apocalypse and she
just happens to know where to take him
when he saves her ass awesome trick
that's never used again in this movie
also the pod is this power I shall take
the sand from a stone pillar and cut
their necks with it I'm making it up as
I go along
death by masonry osmosis I want to the
minds of all memories of us Beach Cuba
well wind up did you do that I felt it
was the best thing for her
goddammit more movie idiots trying to
protect loved ones from emotional pain
by lying to them we were hoping that you
would tell us about what happened
yesterday in Egypt
wait that happened yesterday it was
daytime in Egypt and nighttime in New
York when Mora found
ruins and apocalypse will go in this
case she would have had to go
immediately from the marketplace to an
airport fly 15 hours back to Washington
and get to the office in time for
Charles's visit instead of the
screenwriters paying attention to the
reality of time zones ever since the
world found out about mutants in 73
there have been cults who see them as
some kind of second coming or sign of
God I was tracking one of them because
the CIA is most interested in using its
money and resources to track down colts
who think mutants are gods
luckily they sent me the person who
Charles fell in love with in first class
they think he lived all that time yes
and no they believed he had the ability
to transfer his consciousness from body
to body to use exposition like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
wha-wha also rule credits great fighter
she's my hero I want to be like her but
you can't
she has transforming powers you have the
ability to control the weather so you
aren't and never can be like her
learning from touching a TV in 1983 sure
you can learn everything you ever need
to know from that contraption
they're called learning electrons and
apocalypse binge watches the historical
documents of I Dream of Jeannie to learn
about modern culture we're sure to see
lots of stuff about war here because
every supernatural being who learns
about the world through speed reading or
Fifth Element or how Lucy did it in that
movie whose name I've forgotten runs
across copious amounts of war and almost
zero porn if I can't take over sue are
these assholes still walking away from
the underground cage match please aren't
they somewhere stories taking place yet
sign up gets a little jealous and that's
all you'll ever hear or know about this
character basically how far can you
cover as far as I can see or if I've
been there before but not if I'm in an
electric cage I cannot get past that
because of electricity sorry to break it
to you but you're not the biggest freak
in the school and love cut I thought I'd
see her again yeah me neither yeah it
took six million and the promise of
filming in Europe to convince me I was
afraid this is what Aaron Rodgers said
to get her to go out with him and his
coincidentally the same thing he tells
himself in the mirror before every
football game I know the kind of mutants
you're looking and I know where to find
me how does the god apocalypse need some
non God human mutants help in finding
the mutants he needs like he totally
doesn't right the only thing American
about this place is that it used to be
British when did Scott become this guy
he gets a pair of shades that protect
his eyes from blasting everything and
now he's an asshole
you think I'd knock off a sin for the
movie using a deep cut Metallica song
but when the song says on the nose as
the Four Horsemen it gets a sin with no
remorse this is the guy they took
apocalypse to even though they're very
aware of more powerful mutants like
mystique or Quicksilver Jean Grey or
really almost any other except for that
little who can blink and change the
channel
he's got metal wings that throw knives I
guess his body constantly regenerates
the amount of metal he needs to fly and
fight at the same time no it's cool damn
it it is cool right
you this movie gave Wolverines line to
magneto and this movie should be ashamed
this guy just litters body parts
wherever he goes I'd like to know why
his power leaves certain things intact
is it because it looks awesome in a
movie let's see and that is all it takes
for super independent air to just go
along come and see Jesus if only Charles
had known all these years that this was
the magic phrase to get Erik to listen
to your argument this is where your
power was born um his power was born
when he was because its genetic you mean
to say this is where your power was a
weakened by Kevin Bacon I think did we
really need to go back to Auschwitz to
turn Erik to the dark side didn't the
loss of his new family already do that I
feel like this is already embedded
motivation in the first place we know
this story already we've got to spend
time and a two-and-a-half-hour movie
rehashing it I know heavy flying rocks
and debris expert but this appears to be
a dangerous place to be for anyone who
was in a mortal right now you are
clearly playing miss pac-man not the
same at all it's so much about this
place Moira is working on one of the
most important mutant stories in history
but hasn't thought to contact the school
for mutants for their input I'm just
saying Empire is still the best it's the
most complex that our most sophisticated
here's a popular Star Wars opinion being
presented to something fans were saying
on their way out of having seen Return
of the Jedi which is simply not the case
Empire rose to prominence years after
the original trilogy completed and this
already trihard movie is now overdosing
on try harm you'll be going for humor
ends up with a morbid prediction also
this is 1983 or very few franchises
actually had a planned continuous story
overall trilogy you can't make a
definitive statement like this as if it
were common in 1983 to have trilogies
like this so up the Academy was released
in 1980 so if this theater is still
showing it in 1983 along with Return of
the Jedi
it's in rough financial shape I mean to
turn it into a real campus University
not just for mutants either
for humans - about humans yep Charles
has somehow been too afraid or too lazy
to use cerebro to look for his lost
friend Erik all these years and stays a
future past that's actually supposed to
be believable but one visit from
mystique and his gripping look for Erik
using cerebro fear is released I'm
connected to all of their minds oh you
are you connected to all mutant minds or
not these two statements uttered within
ten seconds of each other mind you are
entirely in Congress these are all the
mutants I'm connected to all of their
minds and I will explain this process
again in this movie because we're trying
to match the number of times Bruce
Wayne's parents were killed in movies
you think because you can see into my
head you know how it feels actually I
thought his power gave him more than
just access to your brain but also
emotions but I'm the least concerned
about this person on the entire planet
so I'll just sin and move on so I can
help you oh yes this movie gave Erik a
new tragedy in the loss of his wife and
child but still this is the exact same
argument these two have been having for
all the x-men movies how did you not
already know that either cerebro totally
missed the mutant standing close to Erik
or Erik somehow block them from his mind
someone's taking over cerebro at this
point you're basically dealing with God
the very idea that this guy could be
defeated as a fantasy dialog is starting
to sound more and more like Radiohead
lyrics as the movie goes along yes in
the event of nuclear holocaust Stan Lee
will die just like you and me making
cerebral work as hard as hell in these
movies but breaking that damn near
impossible for some reason even though
control over anything my brain does
anymore I do have enough backup good guy
power to tell you what needs to be done
to save humanity I feel like this could
have been done way earlier but you know
plot sequencing I'm glad he's here
because Quicksilver is the best thing
about the last couple of movies but damn
this is amazing timing first off let me
remove the reasons before I start being
an asshole about this scene the problem
for me is I know Quicksilver is like
super fast like our minds can't even
comprehend how fast he is but even if
he's faster than the speed of light
which he's not he's somehow able to save
everybody in the mansion going inside
then outside inside then outside an
explosion like this wouldn't take
terribly long to blow the whole mansion
but we're supposed to believe he's
quicker than this some of them and I
ain't buying it I love it but I ain't
buying it also you know it'd be great
after seeing something like this the
normal speed version on videotape or
something did Quicksilver just kill
these two kids who
blows up the x-men mansion like it's the
Starship Enterprise or something the cop
team why because in the last movie she
was an evil attempted assassin pretty
sure I got everybody
Alex was closest to the blast which I
guess means he's dead then Quicksilver
cup that badly was it because he spent
so much time slow mowing around with
dogs and pizza cuz I bet it was anti
mutant power gun seems like an awesome
weapon against mutants so of course it's
never used again in this movie
thankfully Stryker is disabled all
mutants weapon which is some bull by the
way didn't reach far enough to affect
these teenage mall visiting slackers
phew
I know gene doesn't have much control
over her powers but maybe she might try
to infect the minds of all these
soldiers and make them just go away
especially after this dude doesn't see
them and gives the all-clear seems like
she could do something to stop this
other than the plan that she comes up
with later I can't some kind of
electrical field prevents genetic
mutants from using their powers because
electricity and genetics are so
inextricably linked and such these
characters are all sad about havoc dying
and I don't blame them it's just that
have we really ever gotten to know that
dude over three movies he's basically
done nothing right I had to look up this
guy's name like ten times during this
one movie alone character and actor
because these x-men movies can't seem to
escape previous plot points and
emotional motivations we now return to
alkaline lake o Jawa Olivia Munn poses
for her action figure here because she's
given nothing else to do whatever it is
you think you saw in me Charles I buried
it with my family
families Erik families that event
emanated from exactly where we found you
at the home of the world's most powerful
psychic so you're going to tell me where
is Charles Xavier if the whole point was
to find Charles why did they leave all
the other possible witnesses lying on
the lawn outside and why didn't they
check the mansion they just flew in shot
some sort of unconscious cannon rounded
up the few main characters and then
bounced what did you mean when you said
someone more powerful than Charles
what's Hank not there during the whole
cerebro event
[Music]
wait a fuckin second the last time we
saw Jean Scott and Nightcrawler they
were in the back of the helicopter you
know the one where they have the special
force field that keeps them from using
their powers so how in the did they get
out of that helicopter did Stryker turn
the force field off when they landed and
why would he do such a stupid thing like
that during this massive worldwide
telepathic message a lot of this traffic
continues to move normally in New York
man they don't get distracted by I guess
no reason for a magic mutant force field
in this area what could go wrong also
they sure found a way to shoehorn
Wolverine Weapon X into this movie
didn't they yes nothing to do with this
fucking movie but here he is and is this
even a teaser for a later movie and the
next movie is old so I guess they're
gonna skip this part of the Wolverine
evolution and this was just a big excuse
to get some Wolverine action into the
movie this would be badass Wolverine
fight scene is rendered moot by this
movie's pussyfooting pg-13 rating thank
you pussy footage
this goes on for some time an hour and
38 minutes into the movie and I'm still
wondering why the hell apocalypse needs
any of these assholes to complete his
plant he looks like he's doing just fine
on his own destruction on a scale so
large it will take seven whole days for
Lex Corp to fix it hey guys flight suits
which we'll all surely for this wipe
clean this one was there even any need
for apocalypse to tell the world he was
gonna everyone fit up and start his
godlike rule if he was just gonna
destroy the fuck out of cities like this
really the only reason why someone this
powerful needed to send a message in a
movie like this was to give Charles an
excuse to send a secret message to Jean
once again the bad guys main weakness is
boasting we called ourselves the x-men
reminiscing well it kind of looks cool I
can think of no reason all-powerful god
apocalypse would need his underling
magneto to pull a centuries-old ship out
of the ocean whatever weapon he intends
to make out of this ancient metal surely
there are easier ways for him to do it
considering he's a all-powerful God and
holy Sh apocalypse had time to make
statues of the horsemen I mean I thought
this was just a starter temple but he's
already decorating he's dying to
transfer his consciousness into the
professor if he does that he'll have the
power to control every mind in the world
pretty much confirms that apocalypse
could have done this first before making
Charles do it which led to him sneaking
a message to Jean but that's an
inconvenient detail these filmmakers
hope you don't notice this girl is
playing young storm and I mostly feel
sorry for her since I don't think she's
spoken more than one or two lines of
dialogue this entire movie good news she
got the role of storm the new x-men
movie bad news you have practically no
lines
yeah it's what's her name again
and then the job that really what's her
name anyway
Aaron Rodgers girlfriend cut the car in
half but the piece is still nearly
killed storm so I'm guessing if you ran
a simulator 20,000 times storm will be
dead in 90% of the scenarios Olivia Munn
gets the Ray Park one-line treatment
proving Bryan Singer's at least not
sexist I know you think you've lost
everything but you haven't this
eventually works you have more family
than you know well that's the end of
Quicksilver because everyone who gets
close to Erick dies
sorry kid if I could tell you to avoid
Ultron I would let's talk about
apocalypses plan which was to wait
thousands of years to be resurrected
then recruit a team of four horsemen
helpers that each still have issues then
attack the entire world so that the
x-men will respond then kidnap Charles
and hook him up to this convenient duel
slab Egyptian ceremony thing and you
know what I'm done right here this out
of control in the name of a few pre
planned effect shots you assholes have
allowed this film's plot to veer into
the territory of the insane should we or
should we not follow the advice of the
galactically stupid this procedure that
formerly required a parade and
incantation several onlookers and the
son to be just right in the sky now can
be done in two minutes flat and positive
seems a inch bigger than yourself movie
pads it's already ridiculous run time by
showing flashbacks to previous movies
Jesus movie and and oh I like that cute
she thought the guy who was buried under
a rock for several millennia and has the
power of God was gonna die from this hey
remember when apocalypse use sand to cut
off those guys heads but never used it
again in super obvious situations like
this one she's not the real
what's-her-name then what the fuck is
the real what's-her-name doing
I guess she's somewhere jerking off this
movie is super not fun this is Charles
physically beating a man in some sort of
dream state I don't know what the
punches really represent but I guess
this is causing some sort of pain I
don't know a fight between mutants with
extraordinary powers devolves into a
punching match basically yep Charles
pretty much kept the rules of Inception
there Apocalypse knew he was in a dream
and the projections took over
rookie mistake Magneto's definitely the
type of guy who enjoys dramatic
entrances and taking all the surprise
out of an attack he could've blindsided
apocalypse wit this seems kind of early
for Jean Grey does suddenly burst into
Phoenix right
she was just learning her powers now she
can full-on blow up just like that never
caught that woman's name yeah well hold
on
what did I miss yeah they had to figure
out a way to keep Nightcrawler out of
the last battle because it would've been
too cool for him to be in it
mystique told me he is your father she
did what an asshole your x-men don't get
used to this face class because I'll
probably change into whatever the next
big thing is JLo out robots in a Marvel
movie get the fuck outta here another
marvel end credits scene another
mysterious case full of evil technology
and oh no essex not Essex
as Essex that's a sinister reveal
sinister indeed
but I've been going through the motion
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
[Music]
John yeah fuck you too kinda low to
introduce myself
they call me Ivan Ben Wow
Nabu when you try and find him well
hello mystique major striker striker